[Musique]
dans un rapport l'institut pour le
développement de l'information
économique et social l'idée ios dressé
en 2019 plusieurs constats sur l'état de
l'information économique d'abord les
français ont globalement si on peut
faire une généralité un peu facile un
défaut de connaissances en économie les
rendre en globalement méfiance vis-à-vis
du modèle ou des mesures économiques
actuelles ou pas assez critique
l'économie par forcément importante du
fonctionnement de notre société bah on
la subit un peu et cela notamment parce
que si elle est finalement assez bien
représenté dans l'offre médiatique elle
est bien souvent soit trop simplifiée
soit pas assez vulgariser pour être
accessible au plus grand nombre d'autre
part c'est bien souvent un discours
assez uniforme que l'on retrouve dans
les médias le même un peu partout le
défaut de connaissance économique se
retrouve également chez les journalistes
peu sont spécialisés en économie et les
formations en école de journalisme sur
ces sujets sont trop sommaire du coup
les journalistes s'en remettent aux
experts économiste enseignant censé
apporter une planification sur des
sujets parfois compliqué mais il a
encore problèmes possibles conflits
d'intérêts discours très pro système et
donc complaisant experts autoproclamés
et pas assez compétents se pose enfin la
question de la concentration des médias
même s'il ne s'agit pas de remettre en
cause l'indépendance des journalistes
cinq des sept grands quotidiens
appartiennent à des milliardaires
industrielles de même que la plupart des
chaînes d'information et des radios